[Music]
foreign
did you know you are using an algorithm
[Music]
algorithms aren't just complex sets of
instructions for computers anytime you
follow a replicable step-by-step process
to accomplish a task those steps are an
algorithm
my bedtime routine is a pretty simple
algorithm I take a shower put on pajamas
brush my teeth and get into bed it works
every time
but what happens if I'm out of
toothpaste now my brain needs a
different set of instructions should I
run to the drugstore what if they're out
of my regular brand of toothpaste those
sorts of decisions create new and
different parts for me to complete my
task this is how algorithms get more
complicated
when we program computers we're giving
them instructions for all the possible
Parts they might need to take stemming
from all the possible series of events
that might occur in a particular process
stock trading encryption traffic
modeling
and social media
are just some of the applications that
use or require complex algorithms
and machine learning algorithms can
perform new and unexpected calculations
and predictions the main thing to
remember is that algorithms aren't just
for computers and programmers they're
how we all get things done every day of
Our Lives